pourquoi on rigole bien
manga
dans les profondeurs marines ou pop et
ses amis sont comme des poissons dans
l'eau
ils vont être leurs donjons à l'autre
mais un jour là
est-ce que tu pouvais te faire mieux que
sa pop est prêt à tout pour sauver ses
petits frères allaient trop vieille pour
ce genre de mission paix même si bien
sûr mais même si tu retrouves ses yeux
comment tu vas t'y prends pour les
ramener ici prend garde il ya tout un
monde que tu ne connais pas
ça demande beaucoup trop de travail je
me contenterai de ce que je chante
une lutte inquiète pas je suis le régime
devient aujourd'hui un problème tu es
trop petit pour jouer les casse cou à la
surface trimestre grâce à une invention
extraordinaire pop et ses amis vont
partir à leur recherche
un jour mémorable cet hiver l'océan
s'invite sur la terre ferme pour une
grande aventure danois choo
les péripéties incroyable
des rencontres improbables des instants
inoubliables
c'est vrai que dit comme ça ça a l'air
vraiment marrant
pop à la découverte du nouveau monde en
3d
m